I can tell you
something uh
so so proof gold is a cryptocurrency or
blockchain uh supporting formal logic
formal proof and form formal
ma uh it's it's buil mostly on a project
called kitas which I will say something
about
later uh I will explain maybe to some
extent these Concepts like proof of AK
and proof of burn uh but the point is is
that it sort of isn't some sort of heavy
Bitcoin proof of work energy mining but
but it's sort of an interesting
combination of two ways how to secure a
blockchain and it's also interesting
because it's relying on another
established blockchain called Litecoin
which is like the younger brother of
Bitcoin uh it allows what you would
expect from a book chain for form Mass
like publishing theories definitions
conjectures and
proofs it also like I guess the main
selling or interesting point includes uh
Bounty and ownership uh system for like
you can put a reward on somebody else
aure for you and uh that there are some
mechanisms for the person who really
proves the
for his money not to be stolen or
redistributed by by some
C committee right so that's the main
point of blockchains in general the S of
blockchain metor is the is the is the
law right like that there is no Central
Bank which will take away your credit
card
payments that's the the blockchain
people good question yes that one of
those things that we don't know who is
this crus code Bas is one of the things
that we don't know who is doing it or I
will I will set in the next slide thank
you uh it's uh quite a bit based on chat
Downs uh favorite uh attempts at proof
assistance uh called agal and later my
which is some sort
[Music]
of logic
uh but today you can also interact with
it using for
and to interactive one interactive and
one
automated uh the initially it was
announced in June 2020 by this uh this
memo cach uh thingy which is some sort
of super secret way how the blockchain
people
communicate without revealing their uh
identities so I think the the point the
announcer calls himself Blake Kyler
nobody knows who it is so so it's sort
of mod after this sat Nakamoto think
announcing the the Bitcoin blockchain in
2008 and so like I I I guess the the
reason why people are doing it this way
is that it's sort of the sort of
classical
way of let's announce a blockchain from
so that everybody has a fair CH chance
of getting into it like without I don't
know me immediately grabbing 20% of the
whole money supply to F go support the
blockchain development or whatever and
also people do it this way because they
don't want to be exposed to some I don't
know SEC people suing them in the United
States Etc so so it's seems to be one
one way how people are starting
blockchains uh these
days there there is an explorer that I
will show you
later there are today three to four uh
different uh clients so uh the one that
is like most developed and uh most used
is a spild lava client which I will say
something about uh later the original
one is this Pro gold color which was
basically published when when the
announcement was made and there is
another one which is more lightweight is
BL Gold light
which allows some sort of less resource
of uh like heavy
uh there is also one which I couldn't
quickly find which is some extra
features like for example Atomic SW
between
expic SWS we we wrote a paper for this
fnbc uh formal methods for blockchains
or something like that in
2022 when basically most say
I the clent so so he gave a talk in hi
in
2022 and and later it says I got
this Pro of concept project sorry for
the tles uh which like
finances the the development and hold un
commercialization of of some of these
parts so so these ERC Concepts projects
are directed at some sort of
commercialization of of the research in
European so so this is the
history so you probably all know that
there there is this Bitcoin thing which
was announced by this magical saot in
2008 then white paper and launched in
early
2009 uh and we can spent years
discussing blockchains I I I guess right
so maybe let's not do it here in
2011 somebody sort of cloned the the
Bitcoin uh blockchain and did some
changes which sort of made it
faster uh it's also cheaper and smaller
for for various
reasons uh so Chad Brown uh was probably
an
early uh blockchain SL
Bitcoin uh like aado or whatever uh um
you you would call him so in 2014 he
came up with this mgate website where he
had the idea that you would sort of put
some amount of Bitcoins on uh particular
proofs like so so this Mar just uh so
educational website and you would have
always like a competition where people
would need to register by paying some
amount of Bitcoins and then they would
be competing in soling like educational
exercises and if you got exactly the
proof that he intended written typically
as a system if I remember correctly then
the proof would hash to the private
address uh or to to to the secret that
you need uh to to basically get the the
B connected to to this particular
exercise so in in some sense it was I
think like like the the first idea to to
apply this sort of distributed uh
blockchain uh technology to to form a ma
like the obvious disadvantage of this
like yes it has this distributed
decentralized propeper that whoever gets
the right proof can claim uh the bount
but the obvious disadvantage is that you
need to get exactly the correct proof
like you need to get exactly the pro
chat intended so so that it has es to to
the right uh or a secret for collecting
uh the Bitcoin so like I I think he
didn't achieve much with with this
project uh so then there is company
called
iohk which is related to to these uh
Rich uh uh CMU uh people uh so um
again this is a lot of history there is
a very funny book called
cryptops which sort of recounts the
history of eum and basically iohk is a
product of uh Charles hoskinson who was
one of the Ean Founders who at some
point sort of parted ways with the
etherum people and started his own
company input output Hong Kong where
they were developing another blockchain
called cardano which became big so so
that all made them rich but in 2016 they
they were also developing this
kitas which was supposed to be a
blockchain for for proof basically
so I I I don't know much about it uh but
what uh seems to be the
case and again I I haven't done too much
sort of historical digging to to compare
the code bases is that
basically caras was was never launched I
I I don't know what what happened then
at that point like why it never launched
Etc uh but like the code was put out
there
publicly somebody forked it in 201 17
creating something called D Coin and I
don't even know whether it ever ever ran
and and then basically based on this
kitas and uh the pro gold uh code
emerged which really started to run in
2020 there in in between there there
were different other ideas like for
example this MAF coin in 2018 which is
also like an interested reading about
like the world of blockchains and
Mathematics uh then
uh basically Cesar Kishi got involved in
like 2021 and 22 starting to work on
this laa CL and the SL client appear
then say started to work on on the Lego
Explorer uh in my 23 in
24 and this year there's mym wikii which
is linked to the through gold Explorer
imer so so somehow these two things are
now somehow connected so you can s put
some formalization done in Megalodon
into the wi key and that sort of for
example creates the proof go documents
that go into the
blockchain and from the Explorer you can
s of Link back to to
the I'll show you some
examples uh so so so a bit
about uh this uh this this
Wiki uh so um it's it's
a I I think calling it ay like today you
might call it just some sort of GI up
page with
htmlz uh I may maybe quickly skip
forward to example so so
you this is too small to see but it CHS
like one proof like one theem and it's
proved uh written in megal system and
HTML so uh some of these things will be
clickable like for example up there
there are the links to the through go
Explorer and it sort of shows you the
occasionally some hyperlinks to to the
symbols uh so so that's the point of
this like uh formal ma we keys that you
you uh have uh some sort of automated
verification hdmz and in this case also
like connection to for the
blockchain uh so so basically it's some
sort of
GitHub uh GitHub prepo these days which
people can clone Fork edit Etc it it's
guarded by by some sort up action fr the
verification HTM isation and uh if that
fails then get will not accept it
Etc
uh
and I guess uh you can uh maybe you can
also try to look at it in a browser if
that uh thing will
work uh so let's
see uh so which one was I looking
at um
Part 12 let try to go
there and yeah maybe this a small
readable I was showing
before uh
so I don't know this this seems to be
simply but even I understand it so so
this this probably defines the the set
of real uh numbers
is it
true these are the
complex uh elements of the complex
number set the real part of
Z equals
z so so it's not a definition in secure
theor and the theor is
pro and let's see if we can click on on
this uh thing yeah so so now we sort of
got ourselves from the
Meg to
the blockchain Explorer so you can see
that like these um these statements also
with in the Explorer you you have all
sorts of uh information about
uh
the this statement like what is its
proof uh in which theory was it proved
what is its type
uh uh is it name then you you have like
it's through gold address and some sort
of met who
create I
don't yeah um is fine um why is the
proof language so unbelievably for
boasts like the first proof is a one
liner and a decent proof
assistant you patter match patter match
patter masch and
then oh so we can get into flly Wars
about proof languages here but like this
is Chad's thing
so like if if you for example look at
the metam proof EXP Explorer you will
you will get probably similar verbosity
I'm not sure so so this is not an
isolated event but yeah that's
like
I I will not engage like you to have
this flameer Mist in n and like yeah
there is in this formal proof world but
um yeah if you if you want another Pro
format complain to cat
oh that might have
been sometimes are motivations for for
like Isabel is also wildly uh verose but
it's not an accident right it's by
designed for a whole bunch of purposes
so sure I mean this is this is doing a
natural language reproduction of the
this is not the actual proof term this
is trying to explain the proof term to
you right and so it's doing and and it
only has the core proof term but it's
reconstructing like rewrite the current
goal blah blah the proof term is like
trivial in the previous one just yeah
yeah I mean but I mean well trivial
still means well you have to introduce
your variables and then observe that
it's reflexive if you have pattern
matching it's like you know the first
four yeah this language doesn't have
pattern matching this language is like
high order logic right so the higher
order you know it's not a
builtin I'm trying to get the proof in
the proof language which is actually
more moreos to make you even
happier oh another
right
uh
no I mean fancy proof languages have
complicated implementations you don't
necess want to put complicated
implementations on a blockchain right
yeah sure that's why I'm asking right
what's the motivation here why yeah well
I I don't know if I have the slide but
so maybe let's um switch to the uh
slides here oh yeah these are some
screenshots I now show you left I I just
put them but like not to forget your
point or Mario's point the the thing I
I'm not sure if I have
FES is that for for these
applications you want to avoid um some
sort of blowups right like somebody may
try to attack the blockchain by various
means and uh so you could have like a
very compact powerful proof language in
which you write something like an acon
or and then what do you do right like
then like in
uh here uh there are like two kinds of
limits there are limits on the size of
block like the proof in in the partical
instantiation of of of proof gold cannot
be bigger than half megab like like in
that particular format and on top of
that there are some sort of resource
limits inside the proof Checker which is
sort of part of the client of the of the
software which will hopefully PR some
sort of a well if if it simply runs out
of the resource limits then the the
client should refuse uh to sort of put
it into into the blockchain or it's not
a legal so so yes there there there are
these things and I I guess it's it's
notal to to do them because if if really
somebody hates you then then they will
try to exploit some some weakness like
like this in the blockchain and then you
might have to do something like like do
a hard for but I don't know like for
example the Bitcoin people really hate
doing hard works right like the EC
people don't hate doing hard works but
because of some other people hate people
so so this is a very
complicated oh yeah so this is a bunch
of uh
screenshots which is really better to
show you I just put them into the slides
case the demo uh
fails uh what is interesting is that
it's being used for all these bounties
so try to go to this
Explorer main
page uh so so this sort of P
chart tells you that that there is like
300,000 ver of proof gold and on some
open banties coming from I don't know
the a billion in a mappings project the
serial
number formalization the obis uh PRS M
problems like I will show you a slide
about it later you can uh
click on this and you can see the the
the sort of most uh valuable open and
most valuable Collective
bounties so for
example I know maybe I adverti it here
has recently approved Ramsey 45 equals
95 which is like a huge one I prove
improved it formally but it's currently
no chance to put it into this blockchain
but but the apparently somebody to ball
claims it wasn't him
already already collected the the bounty
for for for these easier uh style uh Pro
problems and if you prove ft then you
will get 5,000 to do
it on on a small U page like
f
so 4525 is still
there even if Kevin succeeds I don't
think he's going to collect
well it depends on the on thees
right what what does these numbers
mean like this 750 that's the money yeah
but you have what units right like $5
how
[Music]
much running coin I'm just curious
because I never have imagined that we
have as mathematicians have problem of
Distributing money for proofs except for
few questions that have large sums of
money attached to them so I I mean it's
a cool little project but what problem
this is solving I don't
see okay it's not a little sorry it's a
cool and big project I just don't see
what problem is Sol uhhuh yeah we can
probably discuss it during the coffee
break uh so so anyway uh the the the
current amount of open uh bounties is
like 300,000 the collected bounties
like one of those is worth one micro
Euro so I like like okay we probably
want to start some discussions about
blockchains here I didn't want to spend
too much time on this like like you
probably all know that the the prices of
blockchains are not serously crazy and
uh like when Chad started mgate he put
14 Bitcoins on on his small educational
exercises which anybody who would care
could have collected in one day
basically right so so how much is 14 uh
Bitcoin today if I had done I would be
quite Rich all right so like like the
these things have some weird Dynamics
I'm not an expert some people like it
some people do
it uh for some sort of I don't know
crypto
anarchistic um ideals like like Chad is
probably one of these guys some people
do it because they want to get rich some
people pump it and dump it and some
Ponzi schemes so that's so like there
are interesting books written in this
about this
whole blockchain
is it maybe sorry I don't I know you
don't want to sit on this point so much
but for example there the system in
Internet forms like overflow which is
some point system is maybe iin to that
mode and you know the people who has the
more points have more street cred kind
of thing yeah you you do have points I I
don't yeah there are various things to
the AG next oh
yeah oh what would I also wanted to
maybe show let's let's see if I can do
it oh yeah
um
so so the overall circulation like so so
all these blockchains work by producing
blocks and time time interval so I think
uh Pro gold currently produces like
roughly uh one block per hour which is
not too much and it's been running for
uh 40
years and
uh I think initially there was like 50
Pro gold created during each block like
that's called walk reward in in the
blockchains and I think uh today it's
only like
25 and Big B because of these things the
overall circulation is today like uh 1 1
million proof gold and I think the total
limit like typically these things some
somehow stabilized in this
world what I believe is that the the
maximum thing after it's been running
for 1 million years or whatever uh will
be something like 11 million Pro gold so
today there is like 10% of it uh sort of
printed this is the overall number of
transaction throughout the four years
and the these are aggressive that at
some point help or still hold some
uh uh so that's that's
this um yeah so so there are these
theories which again I'm I'm not a big
expert on but I can probably click on
them uh
here uh
so I think the main
one uh like the the beginning in some
some sort of intuitionistic uh High
logic uh with these two uh simple types
o and
I and implication and Ne
quantifier and you you have these uh
proof terms uh
for K
Howard uh
then there is this HF theory of which is
built in of herit finite sets then
finally there are two axiomatizations
ofas
gr uh there is this
Sy Bing so I think it's
all program uh stuff
and maybe there were some more and I I
think the point is that you can create a
new Theory and start your uh development
and uh can I switch to
this yeah it seems to be
it uh yeah so
the the the bount system is again I'm
I'm not an expert but the the idea is
that you and basically at any time
create um a preposition conjecture and
also at any time you can attach a bounty
or an additional Bounty uh to to that
conjecture
initially there there was this idea
because many people I I I guess in the
beginning of Bitcoin were annoyed by
this idea of proof ofer like people are
soing boring uh Hing um uh contests or
whatever so so I guess many people at
the C ago were thinking like why don't
we come up with something useful like
like theing right I instead of the
stupid mining using hash functions why
don't
we you use this huge power which is used
for mining Bitcoin for proving for
example so so to some extent I think
brug initially tried something like that
so they in each block they randomly
chose uh one of I don't know maybe five
or six uh classes of of
problems and
uh they they would put a bounty on on
the problem and that typically means
that you get the Bounty if you prove the
problem or if you prove the negation of
the
problem uh so so the fact that these
things were randomly
generated uh Wen so bad in the sense
that you would be like throwing away
like completely burning the money
because if you are generating
an unprovable conjecture you can prove
the
negation uh still it
was probably a bit strange in the sense
that it's hard to sort of find you
randomly created pictures for um having
the right kind of difficulty like in the
standard Bitcoin mining the the fine
tuning process like the difficulty
increasing process is sort of reasonable
modulo some obviously new hardware Etc
but still it seems to be quite resistant
where whereas here I I I I don't think
there was any fine tuning process to it
but to to some extent it was like the
idea of you you will get some quote
unquote mining reward if you solve the
these theorems right like in in some
sort of delayed way so in some sense it
was a bit of a attempted solution to to
this Bitcoin mining problem but I would
say a failed failed
solution
uh I I guess the main uh the main
motivation was to sort of get people
into it
initially uh distribute the money reason
about people who can prove theorems and
then this community would be sort of
seated with the pro go and and put the
proof gold on interesting uh
formalization
projects uh so this is an
overview that you already saw in the pie
chart so there are these
Ry graphs for example there's quite a
few of them at some point some hard M
problems coming basically from my ERC
project where added like like the
problems that we really tried to prove
and and couldn't prove using automated
theorum
progress uh to some extent appears
appeared in the
blockchain uh at some point we we
started the this project on
automatically generating explanations
for ois uh
sequences and we generated uh bench
marks for the to prove or disprove
equivalence between two programs that uh
explain a particular sequence and and
these these problems are quite hard
because like they typically require
induction or sort of multiple inductions
and to today's inductive fi proving is
isn't very strong so again like if you
come up with a batter inductive the you
can collect some gold uh Chad BR was
formalizing serial numbers so there is
quite a few cones uh based on his
formalization there is some category
Theory this poos I inms some randomly I
think these These are sort of in the
realm of the originally
generated uh randomly uh generated uh
bounties like during the block creation
so some of them were randomly created
Quantified bu
formulas uh some of them are about some
sort of set constraints which I don't
know exactly what it do high
unification etc etc like the last one
was really like some general random
generation
prepositions uh well then the the
initial code base wasn't uh very
uh
stable for I guess all sorts of uh
reasons so that's why
in21 uh Cesar got into developing this
lava
client and I I guess what really help to
make it stable is that uh it's started
to use like sensible uh database uh like
uh databases for uh for for the various
uh blockchain information
it switched to much uh
better uh crypto cryptographic
uh like libraries like at some point I
visited johis and he he was paid by
Amazon to to work on verifying different
altic cures so he he we we took uh one
one of his uh verified electric curves
um why you can also use the Bitcoin
implementation Etc so so these things
help quite a bit and replace the
original so of native
implementation
and uh yeah the the the new client is
now really stable and the old one was
really horrible to run like it was
crashing all the time the the new one is
now I think it's been running for a year
on some Nots
uh and say also part of this of concept
project started to devel this blockchain
I
show what language is it now it's
still the the this Stu like the gdbm and
altic curves Etc like it's written in C
right or I think John is very fying is
even some machine or assembly but the
the most of is still
um
then I don't know much about this this
is work work so he the works with whole
four so he uh started to basically
import the pro gold theories and
bounties or
conjectures into whole
four uh creating some translations uh
back and
forth and I think he sort of mostly
mostly succeeded in in
that and he he is sort of using all
sorts of automated uh systems that he
created for whole for like holy hammer
and
um tactic to but also like buil in
automation like
M uh to to sort of prove some some of
these bounties
and then obviously he somehow needs to
export them and once he export them you
quite often because of the way these
tactics work in in h for get get a huge
uh lowlevel proof so for for that to to
sort of minimize these huge proof he
actually some custom internal resolution
to uh that sort of very carefully try
tries to squeeze the proof to to this
allow allow size of one uh one megabyte
when he's exported exporting good
gold
uh
yeah I guess yeah I guess I just said
this um yeah
so as I already said like like the the
sort of dream is that at some point
somebody creates some really big project
like like something maybe like Patrick
was showing with this blue blueprint
thing and I I guess this whole thing was
uh to some extent motivated by Tom
halil's uh doing flyp by assigning
bounties
on I I think he even has the Bounties in
the blueprint book but I'm not totally
sure like basically you you
write you have a big project like formal
proof of the cap conjecture and somebody
starts saying okay this slma is worth 50
and this SL worth 100 and now the the
disadvantage of doing that Central is
that like somebody needs to distribute
the bount somebody needs to say whether
this is a proof or whether it's not a
proof whether somebody cheat it or not
if you that LE the sort selling point
for the the blockchains is is that like
these things are decentralized and
distributed so if you have a project
like this you you can be some Anonymous
person in India and if you created a
proof you created a proof you can
collect the Bounty and you don't need to
go through some hierarchy of of people
who who would pay you right so so the
the I I guess
the the motivate the main motivating
idea is the block chains like these
could support distributed
decentralized uh
Anonymous uh formalization like that's
that's sort of sort of the
dream uh yeah so I I know how much I
know about like these things like proof
of stake and proof proof of
burn uh so what what I know is
that uh somehow the lightcoin
network is being used to secure the pro
gold Network so whenever a a block in
Pro gold is created information about it
some sort of hash is also written into
the Litecoin netwk which is quite fast
and quite cheap so so that doesn't cost
uh
money and I I think the idea is that
there are various attacks like
especially if you only have a blockchain
like the these I think the number of
nodes running the blockchain is sort of
today like 20 to 40 noes which is not
too much so if you have somebody crazy
like they might sort of do some H style
overtake of like right like if you have
more than 50% in Bitcoin you can steal
all the money right like so so you don't
want that so so I guess the the the roof
of burand like using the Litecoin
network is some sort of additional
security feature which is saying like
from now on you cannot mess with the
history you s of cannot rewrite the the
history at least that's my very naive
understanding but I'm I'm not an expert
on
this uh well what what is also a
funny uh funny feature is that you own
the prepositions that you
proved and there there is like a
system of um um of like using these
ownerships so for example you can make
other people pay for using your the sort
of
functions in other people's uh proofs
and like there is this joke which I
probably told you already but maybe not
to all of you so so chat really hates
kovski pirs Because he believes that
there are better ways how to create all
all the pirs in set theories so so he
created not just the definition of Kat
but also all sorts of variations on that
idea so he owns them all in one of these
theories and not only that you would
have to pay him uh but but he actually
doesn't allow you to use these
definitions so so you you you can do
such such such weird weird uh stuff in
in in you using like like these
ownership uh
features uh and I I think you can sell
the ownership Etc also like one
interesting
issue is that it's it's quite um non
tral to publish approve because imagine
I know Pro FMA I want to claim my 5
Pro gold right so fine I I create the
pro gold document and I throw it into
the B chain now okay I send it to a
bunch of noes and they say no no no this
guy didn't prove FMA I have proved
FMA so so you have this problem of
stealing stealing the BRS right uh so
for for that uh there is this uh
commitment uh system where before like
like once you have proved something you
don't immediately publish it unless you
are stupid but but I think the system
doesn't even allow it so you you have to
somehow first create a hash of the
document that you want to publish and
you you first sort of pre-commit to to
this hash you are sort of advertising
hey I have a hash of a of a of a proof
and I will publish this proof later and
then I like this message is distributed
throughout the blockchain nobody knows
uh what what actually happen so so they
will put it into the block and once it's
like reasonably secured by by the
blockchain uh you can publish the actual
proof that corresponds to this hash so
so in in that way it's it's sort of a
delayed key which prevents others from
stealing stealing your money
oh yeah so so there is this block size
limit which I don't know what to think
about it uh
you like the the current blockchain
after these 4 years isn't too big which
is probably good I think it's like two
to three
gabes and of course like you do have
blockchains which are like a terabyte or
whatever but then you need by like crazy
people this crazy Hardware right so uh
and also like I said like Theon now has
proof of R4 five equals 25 which is like
two petabytes so so do you want two
petabytes of proof to to live in a
blockchain like distributed on 100,000
nodes around the world yeah so so these
are like interesting questions when you
are uh doing these things like the
Practical solution is is this is this
limit which forces you to split bigger
groups and into into
Lamas and like there is this issue of
like trying to prevent some sort of
poisonous proof some sort of attacks on
on the computation that goes on in in
the Norms
body uh by putting some sort of gas
basically into into the proof
checking
and yeah there is this isolation of
theories to contain potential
inconsistencies so yeah if you find a
contradiction in K gret and you can
claim F right I think if you find a
contradiction in TAS gr you should be
famous so so
maybe
yeah
uh yeah so this is sort of the the end I
guess so it's it's a reasonably Active
network these days like people are
putting all sorts of uh bounties proofs
uh theories into it
uh people are working better clients and
explorers and even interfaces to to
proof
assistance and I I I guess like none of
this is like crazy at this point like I
think if it sayar didn't get into it
then then it would be like a
really almost nonworking project because
say is a very competent uh hacker it it
sort of became pretty usable and is is
becoming uh quite interesting especially
like this connection between the the
Explorer and and and the wiki Etc like
obviously like that there is s of
questions like like would you like like
to create connections to other proof
assistants would you like to create
particular theor like I don't maybe dtic
could be a good candidate because sort
of providor Mario mm Z right like you
you could sort of think about some sort
of other bottom bottom uh layers for for
doing large scale distributed proofs and
then can you can you actually do it in
the system or do you need to create like
a slight variation of the system and how
do you deal with all these things
Etc um
yeah
so yeah I think the the main the main
challenge is like how to make it usable
like whether it actually can be made
usable in in the current U current
instantiation like there are people who
use it uh like what Chad always says is
that he thinks that the intersection
between the blockchain community and the
formal proof Community isn't isn't very
big so so it's it's like a niche uh
thing but like some people believe in it
right like for example chat uh so it's
sort
of I I don't know like how how this will
develop like it could die it could go
crazy it could sort of remain where it
is like I I guess we will see also
depending uh how much people will invest
into it and play play with it and
actually use it like
so uh
to yeah this this is the um web page of
of this uh cesaris uh
commercialization uh project so so there
was the question how how much is it
worth like if you I know today have like
1 million good go and the total Supply
will be like 11 million how how much is
one pro gold worth and I think so so so
the way how to get Pro go like you
cannot buy it at some exchange but
mightbe some future but you can do a
thing called Atomic swap typically for
Litecoin because it has this close
relationship to
Litecoin uh quite
easily so there are some historical data
about prices and at some point it was
like I don't know maybe like $6 for one
pro gold so so if you if you proof FMA
you would get
$330,000 but I I think the price
recently dropped below one uh $1 for one
proof go so but I I think it's a bit of
a very immature Market in in the sense
that that the price can really fluctuate
and the market isn't really deep right
so so like I said you see all all these
effects that happen in the
cryptocurrency world like these pumpings
and
dumpings right so in in the sense
occasionally there is some value to it
like if you if you said okay the to
Supply is 11 million and it can climb up
to to 6 million then maybe the value is
somewhere around 50 million but well
maybe also not right like maybe the
value is sort of zero or is just fun or
for some people like chat okay so that's
it thank you
[Applause]